we got a big victory for racial and
sexual justice yesterday
when united airlines tweeted out quote
our flight deck
should reflect the diverse group of
people on board
our planes every day that's why we plan
for 50
of the 5 000 pilots we train in the next
decade to be women
or people of color this is very
important because what they're saying is
they're going to be implementing
a new reinvigorated affirmative action
program
for airplane pilots people whose job it
is to
shuttle hundreds of people at a time at
hundreds of miles per hour
through the sky in a tin can and if
they're
focusing on race and sex they're
obviously not focusing
on the best pilots that's not purely a
meritocracy but that's okay because it's
it's a matter of racial justice and i i
just can foresee it that when that plane
you know god forbid someday is going
down
and everyone's screaming i'm gonna be
the nathan hale of affirmative action
i'm going to say my only regret
is that i have but one life to give for
diversity
equity and inclusion i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday
speaking of racially charged matters
comes from old school who says
there are two possible outcomes that
will will happen in the streets
once the chauvin verdict is read in the
george floyd case
one riots robbing and burning in anger
or two riots robbing and burning in
celebration i
i'm sorry to say i think you're right
we know that number one is possible you
had a blm
activist say that on tick tock and it
went viral saying all hell's gonna break
loose
if you if you let this guy off or even
if he doesn't get the harshest sentence
but also yes if the if it's a
celebration we've seen plenty of
celebratory riots
over the years i fear this one will be
no different nothing says justice quite
like burning down someone's small
business right
nothing says justice quite like
attacking
civilians not you don't you'll want to
do that you want to stay safe by the way
when you want to stay safe in your home
you got to check out
ring so much is going on our front door
these days especially for me because i
have my sweet little newborn baby
little june so i'm going to have people
coming over they're going to be
delivering food well that's great i'm
glad to know that i'll open the door
there are going to be people delivering
toys and clothing for the oh great yeah
come on in
there are going to be in-laws at the
door and
it would be good to know that is what
i'm saying before you go to open the
door with ring you can do that you can
see
and speak to whoever is at your door
whether you are
in your office maybe you are at your
bedroom
maybe you are on a beach somewhere on
the other side of the world
by the way with motion detection you
will get notified even if the people at
the door
do not ring the doorbell if someone
stops by if something's going on
ring is going to let you know makes me
feel really safe
when i travel out of town i know that
sweet little lace a cute little junior
safe
it's also a great housewarming gift
because it's futuristic it's cool it
keeps your friends safe and
not that expensive which is my favorite
part right now get a special offer on
the ring welcome kit at ring.com
knowles comes with rings video doorbell
3 and chime pro which is the perfect way
to upgrade your front door
and start your ring experience go to
ring.com knowles
ring.com knowles i understand
certain arguments for affirmative action
in certain areas of society
areas where it you know it doesn't
really matter
that much because like there there is
such a thing as historical grievance
there is
we're conservatives we recognize that
the past has some effect on
on the future and on the present so you
know i can understand it
when you get into the particulars of the
left's arguments for affirmative action
i think it falls apart but sure
some parts of society at the ice cream
shop
if there's a affirmative action oh okay
that doesn't really affect how i eat my
mint chocolate chip right
it's not a big deal at uh oh i don't
know
at the bus station
you know it's still you're still in a
moving vehicle but you know you're
moving kind of slowly you should you
should be all right
on the airplanes i i really i
i think you should focus on merit i
think
you should just have a rigorous test i
don't know how to fly an airplane i
wouldn't pass that test
just a rigorous test to make sure that i
don't drop
out of the sky in the name of some
fashionable
leftist idea but all the corporations
are going woke it's not just united
airlines it's delta airlines which came
out against
the voters of georgia trying to protect
their elections
it's coca-cola same issue it's
major league baseball it's harry's
razors for goodness sakes doesn't want
to have any relationship with
conservatives they want to take our
money but they hate our guts and they
want to bad mouth us and say that we're
contemptible and inexcusable it's all
these corporations
what do we do about it there i think
there are
three conservative responses there's the
squishiest conservative response which
is well you know we don't want to
make this all political and we like
their products and we're not going to
face any consequences take my buddy
harry's please
right that's the as you can see i'm not
exactly uh
giving the strongest version of this
argument but i think i'm getting the
point across
then there is the tougher response which
is
they don't want my money they don't get
my money they want to boycott us we're
going to boycott them they're going to
undermine our politics we're going to
undermine them
that is the argument that rand paul is
giving out right now take a listen
well you know they started it major
league baseball wants to boycott
the whole state of georgia including
atlanta they've already gotten rid of
the all-star game and the draft
and they're doing it because they don't
like a republican law a law that
actually expands voting it doesn't
contract voting
uh georgia now has more early voting
than new york has so it's kind of
ridiculous
even the facts don't mate don't meet
what they're what they're trying to do
but my point is yeah if they want to
boycott us why don't we boycott them
this is the only thing that will teach
them a lesson if coca-cola wants to only
operate in democrat states and wants
only democrats to drink coca-cola
god love them we'll see how well they do
when half of the country quits drinking
coca-cola
when half the country quits using delta
yeah so the thing is is they're all woke
but
they're really doing something that is
against the financial interest of every
business publicly traded businesses
usually don't get involved with politics
because it hurts their bottom line to
make a country unhappy
so good stuff from senator paul i agree
we should definitely not
fork our money over to people who hate
us makes perfect sense this is kind of
the libertarian answer which is you
boycott us we're going to boycott you
okay but there is
a further possibility here
which is use the state
which is use politics and the political
power we have
to at the very least deprive these
corporations of the special privileges
that they've been given
because whatever we would like to tell
ourselves and whatever
republicans have told themselves for 20
years the free market
does not always operate in the freest of
ways and very often big business has a
pretty tight relationship
to big government and delta for instance
has a pretty tight relationship with the
government of georgia that's why the
georgia state house right now
just voted to revoke some of their
special tax incentives and tax breaks
that that only delta gets that are that
are not
standard tax breaks across the board
that was the right response
if delta's going to get special
treatment from our political system
because they bring certain jobs to
georgia or whatever then
when they try to undermine georgia's
election laws
then they need to have that special
treatment revoked we need to get
involved politically not just with our
wallets it's good to get involved with
our wallets too but we also need to get
involved politically
when these woke corporations are as
mitch mcconnell said yesterday
establishing a parallel government we
need to
go in there and prevent them from
undermining our politics no question
about it
senator paul thinks i think these days
somewhat naively
that these woke corporations are really
afraid of
you know get woke go broke this really
affecting their bottom line i don't
think they are i don't think they care
all that much maybe marginally they do
but isn't it weird we know that people
support voter id for instance we know
that the vast majority of americans
support voter id
we know that 70 of black people support
voter id
even though voter id is being called the
new jim crow and white supremacist or
whatever
and yet when the people of georgia
through their elected representatives
pass election integrity laws that call
for
among other things voter id the vote
corporations all come out against it
why do they do that we know that the
majority of americans want
to control our southern border they want
not just to dramatically reduce
illegal immigration but they want to
dramatically reduce legal immigration as
well
according to recent harvard-harris polls
so you've got the majority
of americans a huge number of democrats
coming out and saying we we want
to protect our border and yet all the
corporations are for open borders
why is that well there there's a
obviously a financial incentive which is
that
the big corporations get cheap labor
from foreign nationals pouring into our
country
but as a pr matter as just pure politics
pure optics why do they do it
they do it because the radicals have
attained
what antonio gramsci the brilliant
marxist theorist and communist
politician from the 1920s
what he called cultural hegemony
or they're at least very close to
attaining that because the radicals have
engaged in what's called a war of
position where they've attained
influential positions throughout the
whole culture not just in government but
in
education and in big business and in big
tech and all over the place
and now they're wielding that power so
it doesn't matter 70 of black people
support voter id too bad
we we don't and we're the ones in power
the majority of americans support
dramatically reducing immigration
numbers
protecting our border too bad we don't
care what you think we're the ones in
power
who's going to stop us where are you
going to go you're going to run out of
soda companies there aren't that many
airlines
you're going to stop watching baseball
maybe we don't care all the sports are
going to do it
that is a political problem and that
will not be solved
simply by you putting your wallet away
and not giving them
your money anymore it's a good it's a
good place to start but that's not not
the only place it's going to go
there was a daily wire poll that just
came out on this daily wire conducted a
poll
on the mlb asking this question
is what the mlb is doing right now
alienating you
as a fan 64 of americans including a
majority of baseball fans
delta airline customers and coca-cola
consumers told the
researchers that they are less likely to
support companies and organizations that
insert themselves
into political issues and debates 70
percent of all respondents agree with
this statement
corporations and sports teams should
generally stay out of politics
oh great great terrific or we're going
to send that poll now to coca-cola and
that's going to stop this right
no they're not going to stop i mean it's
i'm
glad that we have these numbers because
to me it just
totally puts the political situation
into perspective
where is political opinion in this
country i think political opinion
generally speaking is with conservatives
on a whole lot of issues but where is
political power in this country
not with conservatives political power
is with the liberal establishment
which controls everything
everything the one carve out i guess was
talk radio talk radio though has been
declining for a while so the replacement
for talk radio was new media who
controls new media well conservatives do
really well on new media
thank you to everybody who listens to
this show you've made it a very large
show with a lot of
listeners but who controls it
big tech can take me off can take
ben off can take bungino off can take
any of us off in two seconds they
haven't yet
or they've occasionally they'll do it
you know they'll punish us they'll
shut down the certain social media
platform or they'll kick us off
this network but they're the ones with
the political control and what they're
trying to do what they're encouraging
all of us to do
is to self-censor don't go there don't
sit don't say this don't touch
the transgender topic don't touch
immigration
now obviously i'm not going to listen to
them but
those conservatives who don't listen to
them eventually they face consequences
for that
requires a political solution
you know when you i
i wish that we could just do all of
these things for ourselves if you want
to
do a very important thing for yourself
and fix up your car you got to check out
rockauto.com
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers to things like
hey
michael is your odyssey an lx or an ex
i don't know what kind of x my odyssey
is i don't even drive an odyssey what
are you asking me that for
then they'll go into the back they will
never have the parts they will go online
where they're going to go probably
rockauto.com
they're going to order the part and then
they're going to charge you twice as
much why would you do that
that doesn't make any sense when you
could skip all of that hassle and
humiliation
go to rockauto.com a family business
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years
head on over there to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the prices are always reliably low it's
not like on tuesday
it's going to be this percent off and
then wednesday it's done you got to time
it nope it's just always reliably low
the same prices for pros as for
do-it-yourselfers
they've got every every part that you
need go to rockauto.com right now see
all the parts available for your car or
truck
believe it or not their catalog is so
easy to navigate
even i can do it that is really saying
something then write knowles can
interview les in there how did you hear
about his box so they know that we
sent you what's going on in major league
baseball right now
shows you the suddenness and the gravity
of this cultural shift
because major league baseball the irony
of course is they pull made they pull
the all-star game out of georgia
and bring it to colorado in the name of
racial justice and voting rights
colorado is a much whiter state and
colorado has more restrictive voting
laws than georgia but it doesn't it
doesn't matter
because colorado's got a democrat
governor george's got a republican
governor
the mlb doing this irritates
certainly conservatives irritates people
of all races
irritates baseball fans and even
irritates
the ex-commissioner of major league
baseball faye vincent
so faye vincent was the commissioner of
major league baseball
he just came out strongly against the
current commissioner of baseball
why so the current the current
commissioner is robert manfred
faye vincent comes out against him not
just in a little interview like oh
whoops you know he's asked this question
he wasn't ready he
no fave vincent wrote an op-ed in the
wall street journal
knowing that all the owners of all the
baseball teams are going to be reading
that op-ed and he wrote quote
the talk shows and editorial pages are
full of questions what is the basis
for acting so forcefully against georgia
by major league baseball
if georgia is racist how can baseball
talk of doing business with china mr
manfred
failed to spell out specific criticisms
of george's voting law
now he's put himself in the awkward
position of having to defend colorado's
voting laws
during my time as commissioner i learned
that the american people view baseball
as a public
trust very important phrase here they
want the game to stand for the best
and noblest of our national virtues they
see baseball as the repository of their
dreams
even as they root for their favorite
teams they don't want
and won't accept anything that separates
them
from the game's history and leadership
beautifully
well put and a very important political
point here much broader than just major
league baseball
public trust i love baseball it's the
only sport that i like
it's the only sport that i have ever
consistently watched
there is something about baseball that
is very american
the history is so rich you think about
these great americans babe ruth
even a little lou gehrig little later
mickey mantle
wow oh the histories the history of the
franchises
how they've changed you can trace them
the brooklyn dodgers i'm originally a
new yorker then they become the la
dodgers i lived in la for a long time
wow you can trace that
i collected baseball cards i've got
signed balls the the sport is so
cerebral
sometimes they say that baseball's the
only sport you can get fatter while
playing
because it's a lot of it has to do with
what's going on in the brain it's got
all these arcane rules
that have developed organically over
time
rules that are rarely invoked the
infield fly rule for instance
it's got all this you know these
imperfections it's not totally
standardized fenway is different than
yankee stadium it's a lot different than
the old yankee stadium
all the all the different ballparks are
different wow oh my gosh how rich
how complex we love it it's an
america's favorite pastime right it's
america's game it's about a
love of country and now
some woke idiots are ruining it
when when blm took over the nfl
and colin kaepernick made everyone start
disrespecting the american flag one
thing i said was at least it's not
happening to baseball
baseball's going to hold that baseball
is a conservative sport
and it and baseball did hold out for a
few years
i think there was one schmucky guy who
who took a knee but the rest
stood up all races all places
but then baseball started to cave and it
was real it wasn't even the players
it was the it was the bureaucrats it was
the administrators of baseball it was
guys like this stupid commissioner
manfred breaking that public
trust society works
when we can trust each other when we can
trust in
the institutions that run society
the government institutions and the
so-called private institutions which
often aren't all that
private and the traditions the rituals
cookouts on the fourth of july the world
series
right things that we all do together
that are part of our common culture
because we're not just individual atoms
floating around in the world doing
whatever we want
baseball right now major league baseball
is
is breaking that public trust they are
sports generally but baseball right now
in particular
they are doing something that we might
say well it's a trivial game who cares
no but just tune it out those games
matter those common rituals matter
they always they always have mattered to
the patriotic life of a country
now we say what public what people
what public trust what what do we have
in common
in america there's always been this
fault line on race in america
going back frankly going back to to
even plymouth colony you know going back
to the the
english settlers come here and they've
got some kind of
at times very good relationships with
the indians
then some more difficult relationships
than there are wars that break out
then black slaves come here obviously
that creates a big
racial issue then a lot of immigration
in the 19th and 20th centuries that
creates certain issues
but there's some assimilation okay
that's great so
there's there's never really been a
common race
and and race is kind of tricky to pin
down there was a common language we
don't really have that anymore there was
a common religion broadly speaking we
don't really have that anymore
there were common rituals we don't
really have that anymore we're not even
allowed to go out in public
what rituals we're not joe biden is
saying maybe we'll let you have a small
party on the 4th of july
may oh thank you joe thank you dr fauci
you're not we're not allowed to do
things together
public houses right that's what a pub is
the public house those are
closed you're not really allowed to go
in there you're not really allowed to
hang out at a bar at least not in a
lively way like we used to be able to
schools no
those are largely closed churches
heavily regulated
what public what people we don't even
have a border
you're not you're not even allowed the
most basic right
as someone a citizen of a nation we're
not even allowed to say who gets to come
in and join the nation
that's called racist or whatever and the
current
regime is not even enforcing that most
basic law
so for instance with these illegal
aliens pouring over the border
two illegal immigrants from yemen were
just arrested
by u.s customs and border protection
near calexico
california both men included in the
fbi's terrorism watch list
and the no fly list according to cbp so
i'm really glad
that these cbp guys were able to catch
them
how many more people are pouring over
not just the poor
persecuted you know six-year-old babe
coming in from guatemala that that the
left wants to pretend
constitutes the entire the entirety of
of this
crisis right now at the border but grown
yemeni terrorists coming in we would we
would have no idea
in many cases if they were to get
through thankfully cbp caught them here
goodness gracious there's a video going
around the internet right now that shows
that
alex jones the radio host
is doing possibly a better job at
catching illegal aliens
than catching and bringing to
consequence illegal aliens
than joe biden is this video i don't
really know take a listen to this
video and then i would be curious to
know what you think about it
this video of alex jones walking around
the camera crew
allegedly catches some staffer for some
organization
loading a bunch of foreign children into
the back
of an suv take a listen you got a car
seat for them
you got a car seat that's illegal bro
where are you taking these kids that's
illegal
if you're getting a traffic accident
where are you taking these kids do you
have a car seat
actually there you go how is this how is
this christian hey the police over here
they got a bunch of kids on the car seat
you're violating texas law
who who is this right here right you got
no comments
you've got those children very legally
you're about to run a human being over
you've got those children in there you
got those struggle children illegally
who are you sir your seat belts aren't
even on
where are you taking these children sir
identify yourself who are you
hit me i'll tell you right who do you
work for are you part of this
organization
not sure i don't know so you don't know
where these kids are going
over there no no they they came from
over there they're not being checked for
covet
so you don't know who you are call the
police we need to call the police right
now
i want to know where these kids are
going you are violating state law
alex jones first of all one of the
greatest broadcasters of our age
you know he says some things that are
pretty out there
but as we'll see some of the out there
things he says actually turn out to be
true but i don't know because i know
that alex jones is a showman
so i don't know if this video is legit
if he actually caught them it's kind of
weird that he had the whole camera crew
with him
but on the flip side of that the video
might be true
it might be real because there are so
many illegal aliens being poured
pouring over the border right now and
people are looking the other way
very often in our political class so it
seems weird that there's packing these
kids in the back of an suv they're not
really in seats they're just kind of
flooding in there what is it
i don't know was it was it staged or is
it just that there's lots of people
crossing the border and alex jones
is an effective communicator and called
people's attention to this
i think it's undeniable that we have
this this problem at the border the only
reason
that the video is plausible is because
we all know that this is happening
right now so what is the political class
going to do about it
probably very little
very often the political class wants to
exacerbate these tensions ben's going to
be talking about this today the
prosecution
against derek chauvin the cop involved
in the death of george floyd ben's take
is that the prosecution is collapsing
you can check that on ben's show also
candace owens show streams tomorrow 9
p.m eastern 8 p.m central on
dailywire.com
you can also get the audio podcast
candace at apple spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcasts
if you need some candace owens in your
feed look no further head on over to
apple podcasts for spotify and subscribe
today
also be sure to leave a five-star review
if you like what you hear
i would definitely tune in tomorrow
night there's just an amazing guest
on there there is a guest i felt so
eloquent
brilliant handsome go check it out on
candace
head on over to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
so my instinct when i see a big viral
alex jones moment
whether it's a rant or it's something
like this
this immigration issue i
usually think okay look he's a showman
this is over the top
this no this can't be true he said
things that aren't true this can't be
true
and then sometimes the liberal elites
prove him right they do i don't even
know if he was right at the time
but they the liberal elites end up
proving him right a classic example of
this
is the gay frogs alex jones famously
said they're turning the friggin frogs
gay
and everyone said how are they turning
the frog's gate and then it turns out
there actually was there was a study
done by yale and the epa that some
chemicals that were being poured into
the water in connecticut
were they were not turning the frogs gay
they were actually turning them
trans they were turning them
hermaphroditic
if anything alex jones was was too uh
reticent
to describe what was going on he was too
subdued and modest
in his diagnosis of the situation well
there's another example of this so
there's a clip
during the presidential debates alex
jones making the allegation
that liberal elites
get blood transfusions to refresh their
dying bodies with the blood
of young people take a listen
biden obviously is way plumped up i
would imagine blood transfusions
that's the most by the way that's not
speculation that's the most common thing
that elites do is blood transfusions
the queen of england the queen mother
prince charles the democrats uh
joe biden uh is not on record doing it
but we know the clintons do it
we know that al gore does it you know
all this goes on
so the plumping him suddenly looks like
he gained like five pounds that's a lot
of blood in my experience
and the rosing of the cheeks i mean he
gained he's been missing like a week he
gained a lot of weight
and i would imagine methamphetamine is
well but i would imagine it's blood
that he was getting that's my expert
analysis of that
that's the expert analysis right oh alex
that's so crazy what are you talking
about rich elites get the blood trends
no
newsweek what are you newsweek headline
can blood from young people slow aging
silicon valley has bet billions that it
will
so just to be clear uh no no
proof here that joe biden or the royal
family or these people are
plumping themselves up on the blood of
the young but
there is evidence that these rich
liberal elites
want to take young people's blood and
put it in their bodies
and presumably plump themselves up with
it
you've got to give the guy credit when
he when he in his
sort of over-the-top manner i guess sees
something
this seems like a bad idea to me the the
putting the blood of young people into
old rich people
because presumably you're not putting
rich young people's blood into rich old
people
presumably there's going to be some
financial incentive here so you get paid
for your blood or something so it's just
these rich old people
buying the blood of poor young people it
seems
weird to me if your entire
goal in life is just to extend your
physical
existence to try to beat mortality
well one that seems like a fool's errand
to me but it's pretty
ghoulish i mean it's basically the most
ghoulish thing i can possibly
imagine and it comes from this
state religion that we have which is
secular progressivism
secular materialism the idea that this
is all there is the physical world
that's all there is all of our
metaphysical hopes and dreams and loves
and longings they're just illusions
when we die we turn to worm food we take
a dirt nap
i'm going to be talking about this
established state church of secular
progressivism tonight
i'm going to be giving a a speech in
florida
bastion of freedom there i'm going to be
going to ave maria university this is
our first
speech back since kovit you know i do a
tour with the young americas foundation
tour of campuses i was supposed to do at
least a dozen if not
20 campuses last year
i think the goal was 10 per semester so
we're going to try to do 20 had a
ton already on the calendar early on in
february january february i'd already
done one or two schools
and then kovit happened and that shut
down all the universities and that was
it
and it was over i have not been on a
college campus
in 14 months because
of covid that ends tonight we will be
discussing
the perverse secular religion that that
caused all of that
but this is this blood transfusions from
young people this is part of a neurotic
fear of death that we have
the reason we shut down the country over
the wu flu is because of a neurotic fear
of death
we have faced other epidemics in this
country some of them much worse
than the coronavirus we've never shut
down the country we've never canceled
all of our holidays we've never
stopped burying our dead and having
weddings and we've never muzzled all of
ourselves for
years at a time and we're doing that now
because we used to have faith and we
used to have courage and we used to have
virtues and we used to recognize
that you're not going to defeat germs
and death you can take prudent
precautions to protect yourself
but ultimately our bodies are not going
to last forever
and now we don't believe that or we're
too terrified to believe that because
we don't recognize that that there is
more to life than just
breathing there's more there there is
more between heaven and earth that is
dreamt of
in our materialist philosophy i think
finally
some people are waking up there was a
video that went went viral yesterday
of some people in a restaurant they're
sitting around they're having
having a nice meal and in walk the
health inspectors and the health
inspectors want to shut down this
business
want to shut down people having a good
time they are the enforcers
of the state religion of secular
scientific progressivism
and you will comply you will obey and
the people in the restaurant they say
no thanks g-t-f-o
i am a yeah and um
you can ask me
perfect way to handle it if you couldn't
hear at the very beginning
the woman says hey um so you're
trespassing
on my property and you need to leave my
property
right now man the cajones on that woman
if if even a fraction of the squishy men
in this country had the guliyuns that
that lady has
we would be in a much better place as a
society
and then all the people in the
restaurant get out get this is how
all of these health inspectors should be
greeted
when they walk into private places i'm
not saying
we go full maxine waters here i'm not
saying you get up on them and you mob
them and i'm not saying we do that
i'm saying that you very forcefully very
confidently very assertively and
determinedly
tell them to get out they are not wanted
there
i don't think you should physically
intimidate them i don't think you should
mob up on them
but you should be crystal clear you
don't care what they think
i don't i sir i'll speak for myself i
don't care what they think i don't care
what the health inspectors think
i don't care what dr fauci thinks i am
not going to abide by
their unreasonable guidelines which more
and more would seem to be mandates
with the binding force of law even
though they seem to be passed through
really bizarre means
not through the traditional
constitutional order
and that you're not going to listen to
them if if even a quarter of the people
in this country
had the clarity and the courage that
those people in that restaurant had
the country would be reopened but
unfortunately
we're in a country with a bunch of
neurotics who don't don't have
the same kind of gumption that that a
lot of these people do this brings me to
a slightly
tangential point right now but i do want
to address it because i i see this a lot
on
the internet a lot of conservatives get
this
what you hear from disingenuous liberals
when
conservatives and christians do this
sort of thing and they say yeah we're
not going to muzzle ourselves forever
we're not going to abide by
dr fauci we're not going to abide by
that state religion they're going to say
you know
you're not very pro-life you're not very
christian
this isn't very christian of you and you
know it and they'll take like
some misstated paraphrasing of
jesus one line in the gospel and then
use that to try to own the christians
you know say you're not a good christian
there's always these secular atheists
doing it very often
liberals who object to conservative
christians politics will accuse them of
not being good christians i
i raised this question with them i've
never gotten a good answer but i think
this is the way to to respond to them
you have to ask them do you think
christianity is good
or bad and usually what you're going to
hear is they're they're going to say
well i mean if they're being honest at
least they'll say well yeah i don't
think it's good like i'm you know i'm
not
i'm not christian but you but you but
you're not being a good christian
you say okay well if you if you think
christianity is bad
and you think that you're a better a
better christian than me even though
you're not really a christian then are
i better than you then that will confuse
them for a second or
you're going to see like a little
twitching or something and then they
might take a different attack they might
say well look you're i'm not a christian
but you know i'm more christian than you
you're
you're a bad christian you say okay do
you think christianity is good and
they'll say
yes say okay your christianity is good
do you practice christianity they'll say
no
right if they're being honest you say
okay so you so christianity
is good but you don't do it so you're
you're admitting
that you are not pursuing the good you
are not interested in doing the good
so why should i listen to you well
uh i um and they're gonna stammer and
they're gonna
and it gets to a little bit of what you
would call the transcendentals you know
sometimes you hear
people say we we want to pursue the good
the true and the beautiful there's a
relationship between the good
the true and the beautiful and unity by
the way unity is also a transcendental
now we exalt diversity but actually
unity is
is the transcendental and these things
all have a relationship to one another
the good is beautiful
is true there's a unity there
i think we need to be a little more
confrontational not physically not
violent i'm not saying any of that
but we need to know what we believe down
to the bottom we have gotten away
in in the conservative movement for
about 20 years
on just shallow nonsense on just
you do you just don't make me pay for it
well maybe if ouch he has a point if you
want to wear the mask if you want to
obey by this if you wanna
we're all separate we're all different
we have nothing in common just let me
pursue my own
interest or something no that that is
not a coherent politics that
that does not a coherent nation make we
can't do this sort of thing
the political issue i was talking about
this on c-span yesterday i was on the
c-span show washington journal and some
callers called in and called me pompous
and
offensive and all sorts of things but i
felt we ended up having a pretty good
discussion
the political issues have
cultural effect right
they have cultural substance and
ultimately this boils down to
religion as cardinal manning said all
human conflict is ultimately theological
the high priests of liberalism are dr
fauci
and all the rest of the rachel levine
so we need to get down to those
religious premises i'm not saying we're
going to install a theocracy here what
i'm
actually saying is all regimes have
religious premises no matter how much
you want to delude yourself
and so when the scientific secular
progressives
come in and they say we're going to get
rid of religion and society they don't
really get rid of religion they just
replace it with a
way wackier less coherent religion
that that gives us all these sorts of
crazy outcomes
namely dr rachel levine the assistant
secretary of health
who is a man who believes that he's a
woman this question came up for joe
biden
in another poll voters are apparently
split along party lines
regarding how religious joe biden is
because joe biden he describes himself
as a catholic devout catholic oh
all the people around him he's devout
he's got pictures of the pope on the
dresser behind him when he's giving
speeches
and yet he contradicts the faith on very
important matters not just one matter
among
many but even on issues such as life on
issues such as the family on marriage
and
you know pretty pretty important stuff
so how what is his religion 58 of people
according to
pew research identified joe biden as a
catholic
only the second catholic president 31
are unsure of his faith
six percent identify him as protestant
three percent say he's an atheist one
percent say he adheres to another
religion that's not listed
we'll get into this more tonight so i
don't want to get too into it but
everyone knew that kennedy was a
catholic and kennedy wasn't even a
particularly
practicing catholic or particularly
observant catholic
but but at that time we took religion
seriously
so they could identify what his
professed religion was and they could
identify his
his shortcomings today we don't take
religion seriously because we're much
less serious people and we think that
we're beyond religion and we think that
there is such a thing as objective
neutral scientific progressivism or
something that has nothing to do with
religion it's just another religion and
frankly
it's the religion that joe biden would
seem to adhere to much more so than to
his putative catholic faith and you know
some people say we need to get religion
out of politics we need to get the
culture wars out of politics that's the
line from asa hutchinson
that squish governor in arkansas who
vetoed a bill that would prevent
perverts from pumping little kids full
of hormones we need to stop talking
about culture and politics
culture and religion all that matters
all that matters is culture and religion
i'm not saying we need to have broad
debates over how to access the
sacraments that's not what i'm saying at
all
i'm saying our public debates are about
things that affect our political life
taxes crime and punishment parking
tickets for goodness sakes but all of
those have
philosophical and theological premises
below them and if we're not going to
acknowledge that if we're all going to
just pretend like well i'm going to
follow the science and do what works we
are
totally ignoring the point because
science is the handmaiden of philosophy
and philosophy is the handmaiden
of theology there are a lot of people
that are missing the point there are a
lot of people who are not very expert on
these questions
especially of religious conflict name
namely alexandria
ocasio-cortez who was recently doing
an interview as part of congressional
conversations
and she was asked about the conflict
in israel particularly the conflict with
the
palestinian arabs now the the
conventional wisdom here
was that you could never bring peace to
the middle east
if you didn't deal with the question of
these arabs who were in
israel who were in these disputed
territories that some people call
palestine
and that was the key to peace in the
middle east and trump said that's bs
john kerry's wrong about this the whole
liberal establishment's wrong
we're just going to deal with the arab
countries themselves and we're not we're
actually just not even going to address
the palestinian
issue and trump got historic peace deals
as a result of that
so now they're revisiting this question
what do you do with the palestinian
conflict
aoc's answer was i would say
less than articulate
what actions do you think can be taken
to support
movements towards peace both between
israelis and palestinians as well as
within the entire
region such as uh the abraham accords
yeah so you know earlier just now
you and i were we're talking about the
what and the how
and i think that when we talk about
establishing
peace um centering people's humanities
protecting people's rights it's
it's not just about the what and that
the end goal which often gets a lot of
focus
um but i actually think it's much more
about the how
and the way that we are coming together
and how we are
how we interpret that what and how we
act uh
in you know the actions that we take to
get to that what
and so what this really is about is that
it's a question more than anything else
about process
i can't even i've now watched this clip
several times and i can't get through it
without laughing
because it is the most blatant example
of when the teacher calls on the student
and the student hasn't done any of the
reading
and has just absolutely no idea what the
teacher is talking about
so he says hey specifically on this
issue of israel and palestine and the
abraham accords and what do you think
the path forward is she goes
yeah it's really wow so it's about you
know a lot of people are focused on the
the what you know but they're not
they're not really focused on the how
and me i'm more of a how
how girl myself you know i know there's
a lot of what people out there but i'm
more of a how
and don't even get me started on why oh
why we could be here all day it's just
really complicated
it reminds me of that that scene in
always sunny
it's always sunny in philadelphia where
charlie who doesn't know anything
is arguing about the law with the lawyer
who went to harvard and he goes well you
know
there's a lot of uh legal ramifica
filibuster uh you know he's just kind of
using words that
don't mean anything in that context that
is what aoc is doing here
and but she does it with a straight face
she because this is
the consequence of a really weak
educational system
we've all been in class where we didn't
do all the reading we've all been there
we've all been in class where the
teacher calls on us and we don't know
the answer
and we've all tried to bs it and if you
have had a good education
you will be called out for that you will
not be allowed to get away with that
it will be kind of humiliating and then
you'll know that you got to do the
reading next time and you can't just bs
your way through life
but so much of our educational system
now is just bs it's actually
indoctrinating you into bs
that's what critical race theory is
critical race theory denies
the reality of objective truth so you
know if aoc gave that answer in a
critical race to request it's like wow
yeah
snaps that's really profound and so she
doesn't know it the woman became a
congressman and she she doesn't
know that you shouldn't get away with
this kind of bs how transparent
it is what's so funny about this
particular issue israel palestine
is that she got called out for this bs
years ago one of her first
major interviews was on margaret
hoover's
new version of firing line where she was
asked about israel palestine and she
gave some crazy answer
and then she got called out on it and
she giggled and she said oopsie daisy
got called out by teacher i don't i'm
not the expert on this issue
what people are starting to see at least
in in the occupation
of palestine is um
just an increasing crisis of
humanitarian condition
do you think you can expand on that yeah
i mean i think i'd also just
i i am not the expert on geopolitics on
this issue you know
this is the most true statement aoc has
ever said i am not the expert
period she could have put a period there
certainly on geopolitics and certainly
certainly on this issue we're just
saying things that this is what i fear
we're doing now in in throughout our
politics when united airlines comes out
and says you know diversity equity
we're going to have affirmative action
for pilots so doesn't that make you feel
better when you get in an airline to
know that
by definition we are not prioritizing
putting the best pilots in your plane
you think no what
do you you know what you're supposed to
do right you know what
airplanes are and what the hiring
process is and what like safety is
you know what what hiring
airline pilots is for right do you know
what the purpose of that is
what is the purpose of that when i hear
people say
look i follow the science i follow what
works when i hear people say oh ignore
all those cultural issues or
certainly ignore those religious issues
we just want to do what works
things only work
when you know what the purpose of
working is
right the purpose of a lawn mower is to
cut grass
so when the lawnmower cuts grass the
lawnmower is working
the purpose of the lawnmower is not to
make a chicken dinner right if the if
the purpose of the lawnmower were to
make a
chicken dinner then when it cuts grass
then it wouldn't be working right
because you have to
you work toward a goal you work toward
an end i talk about this at great length
by the way in my upcoming book
speechless
controlling words controlling minds this
is why you can't have a scientific
politics
no matter what the high priests of
progressivism want to tell you
because politics has a purpose we
we have a broad purpose outlined in
the declaration of independence and in
the constitution and a framework
established by the constitution
and then we the people engage in
deliberation and self-government
and we determine where we want to go at
least that's the old version of it
now we've given away a lot of that
political power to egghead scientific
experts
who pretend that it's not even up for
debate
what we want to do where we want to go
who we want to be what we want our
national identity to be
what we want to all do together they say
it's not up for debate it's just
scientific and what's the science it's
whatever they say it is it's whatever
they want to do
and we don't we no longer even possess
the
rudimentary philosophical or theological
sophistication to know what that is we
don't even know what the question is
i'm sorry to say and i include myself
among among
this group we all kind of sound like aoc
we don't really know what we're what
we're aiming at here in our politics
so atrophied have we become in our sense
of what of what politics is
we need to regain that we're not going
to regain that by being
wimpy squishy eggheads who talk about
what
what works and deferring to dr fauci and
the science we need to get
much much more serious the only way
we're gonna have a
serious politics is if we get much more
serious about cultural
and religious issues and i can't believe
i've got to give aoc
inadvertently the point here we need to
know the what
we need to know the how and most
importantly we need to know the why i'm
michael knowles it's the michael noel
show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021. today on the ben shapiro show the
state's case against former minneapolis
police officer derek shalvin for the
murder of george floyd
is falling apart but the media continue
to promote the lie that it's a slam dunk
and riots may follow that's today on the
bench shapiro show give it a listen